um okay so so as we've heard so thanks a
lot for the organizers for inviting me
um to talk um so okay so so as we've
heard from math uh in the previous talk
the PCP theorem looks like the quantum
PCP theorem looks like a really
complicated thing to
prove um so okay I want to State here
the classical PCP theorem with a diff in
a different way even even though you
don't really have for those of you who
haven't seen it you don't have to
remember you don't need to understand it
really but I just want it to be written
here in a different way so that I can
somehow refer to this intuitively um so
what does the PCP theorem say it's
probabilistically checkable provs it
says something like that it says um
there is a way to map there is an
efficient way to start from uh some uh
from a given uh problem say a a set of
local constraints um uh which to which
the solutions are given in some way in
coding say the the assignment for some
formula X1 equal 0 X2 = 1 Etc there's a
way to map this to a different format in
which the set of constraints is just
slightly larger and the the solutions
are given in slightly different and
slightly longer format um such that well
if you look at the at the first problem
the first uh the the sort of the the
where we start with um well a set of
constraints is either satisfied or not
satisfied okay so um I can decide
whether there exists a solution to the
set of constraints or there doesn't
exist so there's one constraint which is
violated okay so in the new format
either there exists a solution or all
Sol all suggested Solutions violate at
least 10% of the constraints that's what
the PCP theorem says okay which is
really if you haven't seen it it's a
really remarkable theorem because it
says that there's some kind of
robustness in the way we can encode a NP
hard problems um which
is if you think of for example an NP
problem is a a mathematical theorem and
your solution is a proof and this says
that you can write down a proof in a way
which you can check whether it's correct
by just reading a small number of beats
from it because if 10% of the of the
constraints are violated in case the
theorem is incorrect then you can just
pick a random
constraint and condition on whether it's
violated or not I can decide if if the
theorem is correct is if the proof is
correct or
not with probability with a constant
probability so that's really
remarkable okay and Matt said Matt said
this is the this is the the best
contribution that that computer science
uh has given physics well I think it's
the best contribution computer science
has given anyone in the past uh in the
past uh few tens of years it's really
it's really an amazing
Theory what what what no but there mean
the Practical contributions that
computer science are quite
relevant okay you know actually they're
trying to make it practical the PCP
theorem it's not the there but it is it
does have a lot of practical
implications so people write their
papers in a different way a lot of I
just check order one bits of the paper
correct okay so um so anyway if you're
interested in the history of this PCP
theum so the thing is that it didn't
just the way it was proven it it wasn't
that you know several people just got
into a room and decided well we're going
to prove this amazing theorem and and
out came this theorem what happened was
it was a
remarkable the way at least the way I
view it is some kind of a random walk
between really beautiful ideas that
nobody really had any sense that it
would lead to this theorem they were
just playing with various different
ideas like program checking and a local
testability of of various properties and
stuff like so things that that didn't
seem to be leading and and interactive
proofs things that didn't seem to be
even remotely related to this and and
combining all these things outc came
this this very this remarkable theor um
so if you're interested you can read
this uh beautiful account of the history
or rather a history of the PCP theorem
like any any really
major um Enterprise does not have one
history so this is a history of the PCP
ter by Ryan Odon and really recommended
reading of this sequence of events so
really if we're trying to to prove a a
Quantum PCP theorem um maybe the right
way to do is not to to try to prove it
directly but to to see whether we can
sort of start with some toy problems um
maybe maybe look at for inspiration at
the toy problems that that those those
people who who led to this remarkable
theorem started to play with and see
whether whether these ideas have any
meaning in the quantum world so
so okay so if you see this formulation
of the PCP theorem really one much much
simpler way much much simpler uh thing
that is happening here
is is a is a much simpler question what
properties can be tested globally what
kind of global properties can be
tested by just probing locally a string
of bits by just reading a small number
of bits okay so I want to I want to give
an example of this but really this is
the question that I want to be asking
what Global properties can be tested
locally and then I want to borrow this
to the quantum World okay so locally
just mean order one bit not to much I I
don't want to be specific here but right
now locally means order one bits uh
maybe maybe just a much smaller number
of bits than the actual
string okay so so let's look look at uh
at an example that uh that was really
very influential in the classical story
of the BCP so this is linearity testing
okay so what's linearity testing um
suppose you have a string like this um
which is claimed to be uh the evaluation
of a linear function so it's a function
from n Bits to to one bit and if it's a
linear function it can it's very easy to
see that there is a string of n Bits a
such that F A of x equals to a dox sum
over a IX I modu of 2 okay so this is uh
if and only F the function is linear
meaning that f ofx plus F of y equal to
F + Y where plus is everywhere
coordinate wise modul 2 okay
so um so now suppose this is the
property I'm giving I'm given a string
like this and I just want to ask whether
this string has the property that it is
the table of a linear function that's
the property so this is the question and
of course I cannot answer this question
by just probing a constant number of
bits because I can take a linear
function and change it by one bit and it
will not be a linear function but I will
not be able to detect it randomly by
picking a small number number of bits
right right so so this property is not
testable locally if I'm just asking
really whether it's in the linear
functions or right outside however if
I'm if I'm doing this trade-off between
accuracy and efficiency and I and I sort
of I don't ask really if the linear
function is if the function is linear or
not linear but what I'm asking is some
kind of an approximation I'm asking is a
function linear or is it far from any
linear function far I mean the number of
bits you need to to flip is say linear
is a fraction of the of the total number
of bits okay so this is my question am I
in the property or far from it and then
it turns out okay so so that's the
question and then it turns out that uh
that in this case it's really easy to
detect whether I'm far from the property
or or within it what does far mean so
far means that uh if I if I have a given
string then the number of bits that I
have the humming distance or the number
of bits I have to flip in order to get
into into this set meaning in order to
get the linear function from for some a
this number is a fraction of of the
length of the string a constant fraction
okay
so um okay so so so there's this theorem
by BL sure confused what is what is it
that
um when you say
you're you're going to test locally what
do you what are you going to test what
are you going to ask so this question is
not good because linear or just not
linear is not the question that I'm
going to ask so really the question that
I'm asking is this is f linear or is it
far from any linear function what
information are you going to use okay so
what I'm given is access to this string
but actually what I'm given is ability
to pick say a constant number of bits
randomly from that string and read
them what so tell me again what the
encoding of the string oh the string is
the string is just the evaluation this
is a St the table of the function fa a
for some given a so this is fa of the
first string 0 n Bits this is fa of 0000
1 this is fa of 00 one0 Etc so it's just
a table of F and the I can probe it in
in a constant number of places and then
I need to decide if it's linear or not
or far from
linear and uh it's a beautiful theorem
by Blum Luby and rubenfeld that says
that yes if I just pick a sort of just
three three locations here randomly then
I can decide
meaning okay so here's the test what I
do is I pick a location X randomly
that's an nbit string a location y
randomly and then I also probe the
string at the place xor Y
soor is just uh addition modul two
coordinate wise of the two strings
so um so and I'm testing whether F ofx
I'm just checking whether F ofx St F of
y equals f ofx y right so if it's linear
function it should satisfy this so if f
is a linear function it passes the test
and the point is that if F if f is Delta
far from linear meaning that a fraction
Delta of the locations need to be
changed in order to make it linear
then this test uh fails with probability
larger than
Delta okay
so
okay okay so so let's just I think it's
easier for this audience to think about
it as a code okay we have um our
property the set of linear functions can
be viewed as a linear Subspace you can
also see it as all as a space span by
all rows in a hamard matrix acting on N
cubits okay so so if you switch zero to
one and and one to minus one you do this
mapping then multiplication becomes
addition becomes multiplication and and
uh and this set of function is just the
the strings of the the rows of the Hader
Matrix so this is a
Subspace um and then we have three local
constraints on this sub space so for all
X and Y we have a three local constraint
at x y and x y and and this defin sort
of a
hamiltonian okay over all possible such
triplets and then this is and the random
constraint looks like this so we require
that this happens and so the test is is
the word is the given word in the code
in the Subspace or far from it which is
Delta far um means that what we require
is that if it's far then the number of
violations the number of constraints
that are violated divided by the total
number of constraints is at least some
constant okay so what does this mean in
in physical language it means that um if
the error if there are many many errors
then the energy in this hiltonium is
large
okay yeah so is this uh okay
so um okay so this so this uh this idea
can be extended so this question is
actually a very fundamental question
what kind of properties can be uh what
kind of global properties like being in
some Subspace some simp simple top space
can be tested to within good probability
by uh by some by probing a constant
number of of locations in the string so
by just looking at a very very small
part of the string okay so so um so this
is really this qu this can can be taken
to various directions and has been taken
to various directions in computer
science it's really instrumental it's uh
uh it has uh so it started with program
checking uh so it is tightly related to
the question of whether a a given uh
program in computer program behaves as
it should behave um it's related to uh
to the notion of property testing which
does not necessarily have to do with
linear subspaces can can also do can ALS
you can also ask uh how far am I from so
you're given a graph how far is it from
uh being uh three colorable I don't know
you can you can talk about various
properties um not necessarily linear
subspaces um it's it's instrumental in
probalistic checkable proofs um so
locally test so all probabilistically
checkable proofs all proofs of the PCP
theorem use this uh this notion of
locally testable codes so codes such
that uh uh you can test they're defined
by local constraints and such that uh by
picking a random constraint you can
detect that uh uh you can detect with
with good probability with constant
probability that a word is far from the
code okay so
um so such are exam the example is the H
code low degree pols reg code never mind
the names but uh but this is really it
goes in various directions so L the
question that I want to to raise in this
talk is is uh what about locally testing
Global Quantum property
so um can we can we locally what kind of
of quantum properties and I'm going to
be like more prise in a minute but what
kind of quantum properties we can test
where Quantum
properties I mean multi-particle Pro
properties that are really globally
Quantum um can we test by uh by
probing um whatever the information
locally by not getting all the
information but just getting very a very
small part of it now this this problem
can be interpreted in two ways and I'm
going to talk in this talk about both of
them so the first is uh you can ask what
kind of properties can be tested if
you're given a Quantum State and what
you're doing is you're probing a small
number of cubits of this state okay so
that's uh that's the question that's the
first question you could ask you could
also ask um if I'm thinking about class
classical encodings of quantum objects
then what happens can I are there
interesting things that I can say in
that
respect okay
so okay so I want to ask so I want to
look at this problem at this question
yeah so it was crucial in proper in
class
proper that you had this notion of
distance the positive instances I mean
the negative instances were separated
by some having distance from the
positive
instances and so what would correspond
to that in the
quantum uh setting so when you are
testing you are not really testing well
as you said that you are not testing
whether it's positive or not but rather
whether it's positive or very far from
POS right so um so from okay let me let
me answer this through this slide so
here is a possible so let me start with
uh asking about Quantum locally Quantum
so testing Quantum Properties by
accessing Quantum States okay um so then
um the first analog to what we've seen
would be Quantum error correcting codes
which can be locally tested so let's see
what that means so I have a hamiltonian
which is a sum of local terms and and
the Quantum corupting Code would be the
ground space of the Simon
and for this code to be locally testable
what I would require is that first if
size in the ground space then obviously
uh the energy is zero but this also
corresponds to the probability that I
would reject if I try to
measure if I write H as a sum over h i
then SI
H over m is Su over 1 over M Su
over h
i i goes from one to M over all
constraints so this thing can be viewed
if hi is a projection as the probability
for this state to violate this this
constraint okay so this is basically
your reject rejection probability if you
randomly pick a constraint and check
it so um so we want the the right analog
would be that this probability is zero
so the energy is zero or if s is Delta
far and I'm going to answer Mar's
question in a moment if s is Delta far
from the ground space then I want the
the energy the density of the energy
meaning the energy divided by the number
of constraints to be at least some
constant okay Epsilon as a function of
Delta and I call this the soundus um
okay so what does it mean to be Delta
the farm so what we mean is something
which is uh which we've learned from um
from the study of quantum codes it's the
same thing um this okay so so you can
talk about humming distance also in the
quantum world where what you want is
that um um your state would be Delta far
from the code if for for any operation
that acts only on Delta n
uh cubits you will get zero intersection
with the Code Zero inner product on the
code I'm sorry there is but you already
have a have a definition of distance
here without going to defining it in
terms of suing distance in the sense
that this already says you know you
define the local Honan it gives you a
notion of distance you're either in the
ground space your your promises you're
either in the ground ground space or
Delta far now all you need to Delta in
terms of those terms of the hamoni you
oh no no no no no sorry but but but you
could Define it this way and that would
be the natural analog no and then the
only question would be an interesting
ground sorry sorry it's not a natural
analog it's not let me let me explain it
again in the linearity testing there is
the locations where I need to
change and there is the number of
constraints yeah and the number the
constraint correspond to the energy
constraints and the locations of the
error is a different thing so so uh let
me give an example actually with the Tor
code which will which will explain it
better I think um so here's can I say
something yeah so this is just this is a
very very important distinction between
errors and and the constraints that are
being violated and it could be and
that's and I'll I'll talk about this in
a moment it could very well be that
you're very far from the code but only
very small number of constraints shout
and this is this this is why blr needed
to work so hard
they they talk about a state which is
Delta far in humming distance and then
they say the number of constraints the
probability to pick a constraint which
is violated is is large so this is a
connection between the the errors in the
string and the constraints that are
violated these are two different
things yeah but but um what I meant was
this that u in terms of in terms of what
that interesting property is you know it
could be you know you could have have
this notion of distance in terms of
having distance but property would be
well it would be some property of this
ground Space versus everything far
range so so in other words there's this
there's this issue of how do you how do
you map an interesting property in that
you know distinguishing
what so there are so
the result is exactly interesting
because are two different Notions for
what it means far like one is the far in
Hing distance and the other notion is
far away in terms of like number of
violations and so that these
two are related these two these notion
so here we need two Notions right so
what would be the other notion
that's yeah okay
okay is there still it's good um okay so
um I mean it would be so I think that
maybe maybe you're hinting to a
possibility of defining a distance in a
different way based on what would be
interesting and that that is uh that is
a good question I mean that's one and
I'll refer to that later on okay so it's
uh but for now it's a natural way it's a
natural choice of a distance to talk
about huming distance also in the
quantum case and we've learned from um
from stabilizer codes that this is a
very very interesting notion um I mean
the entire theory of error crafting
codes build on this Builds on this
notion so for example let's let's look
at U at the Torah code um so for the
Torah code um you you can have a string
of of Errors along so the T codes like
Matt explained last last talk um you can
have errors so the cubits are set on the
on the edges and you can have errors
along say
uh all the edges in this green line but
the point is that even though the
distance of this error of this the the
resulting word from the code is actually
could be very large it could be the
length of the string here um so
something like square of n um the number
of constraints that it validates is only
two that's a string like operator it
just validates the edges of the of the
string right
so sorry I still don't understand how
exactly do do you define the analog of
uh the Hamming
weight so you you say on how many uh
sites did an error occur because this
might be that even though there were
many errors there was there was no
logical error right and and and so then
you won't be able to distinguish right
so I think for for this talk the easiest
to think about it is think of a
stabilizer code and the distance is
really uh the length the the weight of
the of the error mulle the centralizer
of the of the group okay so you don't
take into account errors that are
logical
Gates this these are not considered
errors is it well defined I mean how do
you count how many errors happened when
you do this
modul uh oh you just take the the weight
the minimal weight modu move the
centralizer
the okay so uh so so with the torque
code you get something which is uh um
which has very bad behavior right it has
only a very small uh number of
constraints that are violated and the
length of the string is very large um
could be squared of B uh and the same
for the foror code uh you can have an
error which is something like uh an area
but the the errors will be along the
surface so um okay so so so this is
connected um and some of you probably
have already noticed that to the notion
of energy Bearer yeah so so what's an
energy barrier um so the energy barrier
of the code um is is the following it's
it's uh if you are in a code and you're
you want to move to a different word in
the code or toal to it the question is
how much energy do you need to invest in
order to do that okay so uh for example
in Tor code you want if you want to move
to another
Co another code word then it suffices to
create just two defects and then there's
no energy cost for letting them just go
around the circle so basically this is
the landscape of the energy for the Tor
code so the energy barrier is is is a
constant and it's a very very
interesting question to come up with
codes which have uh I mean the question
of energy barrier is very interesting
from for physicists and and uh um well
also in Quantum information because of
the of the connection to
self-correcting um memory and also
self-correcting computation so it is the
the assumption that if the energy
barrier is large then uh then the system
is sort
of passively uh protected against errors
okay because the the system wants to go
to the low low energy levels and uh and
go going up in the energy is prevented
and and you need to do that in order to
to perform a logical gate
yeah it right you're talking about a
particular basis in the grand space is
that right because when you're saying
moving from side to side isn't
it uh well I'm talking about uh any word
any word going to in or
to that's true even if you allow in your
combination yeah you just have local
local
errors but it doesn't need be in the
same
basis can't fli signs like take a and a
minus and get something local no that's
the point you have to protect also
against such things because a plus b and
a minus B would would mean a logical
gate which is a z or whatever I don't
know I don't know what
the yeah it will meet some some logical
gate and and uh and uh and that's not
allowed so the energy barrier prevents
from as long as you have two basis
elements two orthogonal basis elements
then a plus b and a minus B are close
right they're close not okay so so you
cannot move for example
um in order to this is a logical gate
yeah you're moving between two states
which encode two different states two
different logical
States so this is not something that I
want to allow without paying a lot of
energy maybe I not understanding the
question maybe you want to say like
imagine the energy is being measured
along the way something like
that yeah but it's important that this
that the steps along these paths act on
qu one cubits at the time they don't
have to act like to go different Ionia
or something but they have to be local
and if you want to do any logical
operator then you know needs order the
code Cub to
act I don't quite
question I think I'm just confused it'll
resolve
itself
um so I think the best picture to have
is the picture of stabilizer codes and
then um and then in order to move to
apply a logical gate is basically to
write down X's or Z's or whatever so
it's a product of PES so in order to to
apply such a string of x's for example
you have to start by an X and then
accumulate those X's around the
line so so if you if you move between
two states of
uh okay I don't know I don't know if
that's helpful okay
so um so anyway this is just essentially
just a a connection it's not something
that I want to get really into but the
point is that um that it's clear that
this energy barrier is somehow related
to this notion of of local testability
um but okay so so has code um um in
three dimension is does have this energy
bar so it was it created a lot of
excitement and I think we're going to
hear a little bit about it uh tomorrow
or the day after tomorrow hopefully um
but uh its energy barrier is logarithmic
in the size of the string so um so in
terms of of local disability it doesn't
work that well because we we want again
it's it's log l divided by L so we're
not going to get any constant or any
nice behavior it's going to be one some
inverse poal so um so it looks like so
energy bar is a much weaker requirement
than uh LTC first of all because um the
energy bar just requires that during
during the path we'll get to some large
energy whereas for LTC we want that
whenever we get far away from the word
then we get large
energy um that's one thing and then for
physicists energy barrier which is
microscopic is sufficient whereas here
it's not sufficient because if if the
energy is microscopic but say it's one/
Ro of n then your probability of
detecting it will be also one/ Ro of n
so it's not good okay so it's uh so this
goes in that direction but doesn't look
like it goes in that direction yes so I
think what people are actually
interested in is the free energy bar so
there there's an entropic contribution
which is very very
important but does it play any role here
um I don't know how to compare this to
the free energy um you also have to know
how many states are around the state of
Interest somehow how the landscape of
exit from from one well to another
whether you have many possibilities to
go out um I don't know I haven't thought
about
it that's a good question um D do you
know how to how these compare yeah but I
mean I think your comment was just that
if what you're interested in is
different from the energy barrier so
well I want to say that they're related
Stronger Yeah but I mean it's you're
never you know if any finite dimensional
code on the D dimensional L your
requirement is never going to be
fulfilled you know you know if if it's a
fixed letter D Dimension well it's not
clear okay let's no you have to go to
these kind of constructions you know
because
the the dimensionality of these
boundaries is always lower than the than
the you know the number of yeah but it's
not clear that you only that you only
have codes with Dimensions okay so no I
mean if I'm just saying say if it's a d
dimensional that is in it's local
interactions that we have a bound on the
this can still and that tell I'll get
the geometries is different I'm not
saying okay I'll get to this question I
don't know yeah okay um okay so it looks
difficult to construct such locally
testable codes and uh and there are
other natural candidates that one might
think about like uh uh take classical
locally testable codes like the read
Miller codes if anyone is familiar here
with those and construct uh CL Quantum
uh read merer codes which are the CSS
version of uh of classical read codes
but then they won't they won't satisfy
they won't be good either because one of
them the Dual or the Primal uh will have
bad local disability so if you didn't
understand this forget about it but that
also all essentially the bottom line is
we don't know of of codes that behave
well in terms of this local disability
yeah
of ask difficult is
problem well yeah it's a
problem it's an it's an open
problem you consider any code or just
ldpc code so when we consider ldpc codes
so basically we consider uh codes with
of which the constraints are
local
um would you happy like this this um
torod on 4D hyperbolic manifold which is
uh you know sort of it has something
like your local testability as long as
the defect is not too big like once as
long as the distance to a code were just
yeah it's I think it's already
interesting for uh for small Deltas
which are
constant Del which is sub constant yeah
um okay so so let me say first of all
that this is really uh there are more
open questions here than known uh than
than uh things that we really know um so
okay but but these things sort of raise
the question of are there inherently
Quantum limitations on Quantum local
disability Quantum local deible codes
yeah if we if we forget about the ldpc
requirement and we just consider a
random CSS code is that locally
testable
um or but I don't random CSS code you
have you need the you need to have local
tests for for it to be local test a few
stabilizers
each okay so um so let's just see what
happens so in order to understand what's
going on in the quantum case let's just
just see what happens in the classical
case so first of all how are we doing on
time I'm sort of uh oh see um yeah but
you had quite a few questions so 15
minutes okay um so
um wait when did we
start too
late 3:40 right okay so
um uh so let's just see what happens in
the classical case so first of all
classical locally testable codes on on
laes don't exist why because uh U well
at least assuming linear distance why
here's a very simple argument
um um suppose you have a code with two
two words S1 and S2 with distance D and
D is linear then just find um a line
like this that cuts say d over3 of the
errors on one side uh at least D over3
but not more than d over2 you can do
that and then switch
S2 uh if this is the values of S1 switch
the values of S1 to the values of S2
here so basically every all constraints
here will be satisfied all constraints
here will be satisfied only constraints
will be valid are along the line so it's
very few but the distance of the word
will be large so uh so when lce is it
won't work um and in fact I don't know
that this argument works in the quum
case
um okay now on the other hand on
expanders it's very easy to come up with
uh with locally testable codes uh using
lossless expanders um random codes will
be uh will be locally testable um
basically because um all constraints uh
if if if it's a good expander then all
constraints sort of uh um uh touch the
error would touch the error only in one
place if the error is not too too dense
and uh if think of parity check um
operations if they touch the arrow only
in one place they will be violated so
the number of violations will be very
large if it's
expanding okay
so um so this is the picture in the
classical case and it seems that the
picture in the quantum case is very
different um so okay what we know how to
show is this is result with with leor um
who's sitting here is there are two
results basically one is that
um when the code is set on a good
expander it's a bad locally testable
code so let me say it more precisely um
for and this works for stabilizer codes
only for stabilizer codes set set on
Epsilon local expanders um I'll explain
that in a moment then um if you're
looking at distances Delta which are
small these are the Deltas constant
Deltas which are small so that these are
the regimes in which it's actually easy
to come up with Lo with classical local
table codes um then the energy is small
meaning that the energy is o o of
Epsilon meaning that it's a bad local
locally testable
code um so what does the Epsilon local
means it means um that if you're looking
at smalls so this is this is a graph in
which we put the cubits here and the
constraints here and we connect a cubit
to constraints it participate in then we
say it's Epsilon local expander if uh
the number of constraints here on which
a set a small set a constant size set
touches is almost optimal um meaning
it's larger than the size of the set
times the degree of each point of each
point here times 1 minus Epsilon so this
means it's Epsilon close to Optimum so
if this is if Epsilon is small it's sort
of
spreads like the tree that Matt was
talking about if Epsilon is if Epsilon
is zero it spreads completely if Epsilon
is very small it almost spreads
optimally
and and if this if this is the the graph
the underlying graph then uh you can't
have have local disability so why is
that um okay so this is reminiscent of
the the the results of Haro and brow um
that somehow hardness in the quantum
case uh doesn't is not supported by
expanders in some funny way the better
the expanders the worse the hardness so
this is also a result of me and and leor
in the context of of of
approximating um approximating QA on
expanders it becomes easy and here too
we see the same phenomena that expanders
make makes things sort of I don't know
they they create some difficulty in in
uh um in creating in creating um so okay
I'm not sure exactly about the
connection but it looks like a very
similar phenomenon so why is this uh why
is this true
um okay I'm not sure I want to get into
the detail of the argument um okay I'll
say yeah but just one thing
Epsilon equal 14 not going to zero then
get beautiful expander which we love
to right so this is a the this is a weak
bound on the theorem I mean you can
always take Epsilon to to infinity and
it there are uh to I mean as large as
you want constant but the point is that
classical codes exist with uh with the
energy going uh almost to the optimal to
its optimal value so this is something
this is a strictly Quantum
behavior um but I guess you could say
there's a there's a giant Gulf in the
middle like if if it's a ter if it's a
really really good expander or if it's a
really really bad expander then it won't
work but you know there's a very big
middle region event right yeah
completely um okay so the proof idea I
don't want to go into the details of
this but basically it comes from the
fact that well we're going to construct
an arrow which has large distance but
low energy how uh take a stabilizer and
then we're going to define the error to
be one of the operators in the
stabilizer let's just look at an error
of at one location later where we can
spread the errors at far away locations
so uh pick an error at one location and
since it CES from comes from a
stabilizer well there are two things to
note one is that since we're talking
about stabilizer codes stabilizer
commute
so um if I want this error to violate
another stabilizer it needs to not
commute with it but that stabilizer
commutes with the original stabilizer so
what this means is that the for for a
stabilizer to be violated by this error
it needs to intersect the original
stabilizer by in two locations and the
point is that with such expanders such
intersections of size two are
rare okay so maybe even you didn't
understand the exact details it doesn't
really matter the point is that
intersections of stabilizers a where the
intersections are SI size two are rare
in expanders and this is the only way
you can get
viations okay
so um so then you can actually get not
only um a bound on expanders but a bound
on the robustness for any Quantum local
testival codes regardless of of the
graph uh by combining the fact that it's
well it's better an expand because of
the previous theorem and it's it's also
bad on non-expanded and this is Trivial
for classical uh case it's it's not
trivial at all at least we don't know
how to do it trivially uh for the
quantum case um if it's nonexpansion
it's if the expansion is bad then
obviously it's the number of constraints
that it touches is small so you won't
have local disability but quantumly
you'll have to somehow make sure that
the error that you start with uh
has a large weight that it does not
reduce modu modu the the code so so um
okay so so you can do this and and and
you have some bound on any
problem but this bound is is weak it
just says that you can't get to
op okay
so so there are lots and lots of
questions about uh locally testable
codes
um okay does this mean that uh so Greg's
question is there an open question here
yes we don't know of a locally testable
codes so come up with a locally testable
code which has say linear distance and
uh and uh
um energy uh which is constant even for
any range of
datas um do they exist on atis we don't
know um perhaps similar methods that we
use to found locally test BL codes can
you be used to to to deal with energy
barriers and self correction I don't
know um now and a very interesting
question is how are they related to nlts
so the nlts that math talked about it
seems that they're tightly related to
them it seems this is really hand waving
um it seems that Quantum locally if you
have a Quantum locally testable code you
also have an nlts reminding you what
nlts means it means that you have a
hamiltonian such that all the low energy
states are highly entangled so why would
you have such a thing if you have a
Quantum locally testable code well
imagine you have a trivial State then um
then it should it should be true that it
it's far from the from the locally
desable codes that's what we don't know
how to show if you have a trivial State
then it's far from the code now if it's
far then by the nature of local
testability it also have high energy
um okay so we don't know how to show
that and the question of relation to
Quantum PCP is uh is uh of course
extremely interesting but also extremely
open um so in Quantum PCP there are
there are in classical PCP there are uh
two basic Notions that are very tightly
related to to local
tability one is uh one is local
correctability
which is suppose this is your string and
suppose this point is is aired now I
want to correct it by referring to two
other random points which with high
probability are not aired then
classically you can do it if a
particular point is is has a has an
error you can use the other point by
using them randomly and correct it can
you do it quantumly can you even Define
quantum self correctability
Quantum local correctability in this way
it's not clear that you
cannot no I think it's an interesting
question um and then um local
decodability so another thing that seems
to be essential in in uh in pcps is the
notion of this is supposedly supposedly
the the string that you encode and this
is the encoding string and local
decodability means that that you can
look at a small number of points and
then you can decode one bit in the
string that you
encoded okay
um quantumly it's impossible to have
this right because quantumly we know
that if if the code has a large distance
you will not be able to decode a bit to
get any information locally so you can't
have local decodability but possibly you
can have local
cability so it's not clear how how
first of all it's not clear to me and
also maybe to guy that local
decodability is even essential in the in
the classical World
um and it's not so so the relation to to
PCP is completely
open
now I don't know how much time do I have
well I think not too
long zero oh zero so um zero meaning
minus one or do I I think I don't know
why do you want us start a whole new you
know well I wanted I wanted to sort of
browse through the connection to
classical disability so I think five
more minutes would do it but maybe I
mean we can also skip it are people
it
okay okay you're you're back what I said
before
okay okay so um um
okay so now we've we've asked about
Quantum testing Quantum properties the
question is what happens when we test
classical properties classical strengths
to understand Quantum properties so
before we're talking about testing
Quantum States now I want to talk about
the possibility of testing classical
strings locally to defer something about
to infer something about the quantum
properties encoded by those
strings and the connection between those
two Notions is a completely open thing I
think we don't understand the connection
between the the local disability in the
classical case and the local disability
in the quantum case when you encode
Quantum properties so let me explain
um yeah yeah so uh so suppose here's
here's an example suppose we want to
test that the ground energy of a given
Honan is zero and not say larger than
one over poy if someone is giving to us
some kind of a proof but it's a
classical
proof okay um and we only we want to do
this by probing only a small part of the
proof so that would be an instance of
classical encoding you get local probing
and uh and uh and you want to infer
something which is a Quantum property
okay so if it if the proof is a Quantum
State then that would would be
equivalent to Quantum PCP thing if you
could do that but now suppose the proof
is a classical string and we allow it to
be
exponential so intuitively it would
maybe at the first attempt I mean the
first thing that you would say is okay
that's obviously possible because just
take uh an exponential uh description of
the quantum ground state but this is we
don't know how to probe it locally to
get any information about it because
even just measuring one cubit is sort of
spread over the entire string
so the question is how can you actually
have such an exponential proof um which
you could probe locally and this is a a
very beautiful idea from very beautiful
connection from computer science
connects this question to something that
is seems very remote which is the notion
of interactive proofs in which you have
a verifier which is a classical BPP
machine and aover which is possibly very
powerful and and that prover wants to
prove to the verifier some something
such that if the verifier if the if the
if the something is correct the verifier
will accept with high probability if the
something is incorrect it will reject
with high probability and it turns out
that if you have such an interactive
proof like
this for this property that the ground
state the ground energy is zero then you
accept the ground energy is large then
you reject um if you have such an
interactive proof you could actually
translate it to a string of exponential
length by basically writing down all
possible answers for the of the prover
all possible interactions and that long
string um basically through the
interaction is only probed because the
interaction is only
polinomial is only probed at polinomial
in many
locations okay so that can be viewed as
a local encoding as as a as an encoding
of of the property in such a way which
is accessible
locally
okay and uh and well such a thing is
known to exist um we know that uh qma is
in IP by qma as in p space and ppace is
is equal to IP the class of problems
that can be proven in this way ppace is
the class of problems that can be proven
can be solved in pronomial space uh so
this is this has been known but the
proof first of all this proof is
extremely complicated it's or I don't
know it's it's uh conceptually
complicated and it's a um and this was
one of the pillars that led to the PCP
theorem so I think it would be very it
it is an interesting question to try to
understand how this looks um without
going through this proof or trying to
understand how this looks in a more
Quantum language and and uh and this is
this is this was done in in our joint
paper with uh with Tom
andai uh in which we we provide
something like Quantum s which which
does this thing in a way which is sort
of quantum and uh and um and well I
don't have time to go through the proof
but essentially it goes um it goes
something like well the problem that you
have to to do in order to do this is uh
is to decide whether the trace of this
operator is large or small turns out to
be suffice to do that uh if you know how
to do that then you know how to solve a
c you know how to distinguish between I
value zero and I value one over Po and
and in order to do that well
um you need to find an interactive proof
for the for the trace you need to allow
the prover to to convince you that the
trace is something without being able to
cheat and um
and essentially it's done by uh by um by
by providing a protocol such that the
prover needs to be consistent all the
time with its previous answers so um so
the verifier is interrogating the prover
and the prover needs to answer and needs
to be consistent all the time with the
previous answers and the the actual
protocol which I'll be helping to
explain later is is is the following you
have a huge Matrix you want to the the
prover to convince you that the trace of
this Matrix is
something he tells you some value then
you ask him to give you the reduced L
Matrix of the first Cubit exactly and
this is sort of the prover this is
exactly equivalent to the prover
committing to the values of the trace of
the original Matrix conditioned that the
first Cubit is in some state but he's
committing to the trace for all possible
States so by providing the reduced anx
of one cubit he's committing to the
value of the trace for all possible
restrictions of the first Cubit and then
the verifier sends him a request Now
give me the trace of the Restriction of
of the entire Matrix to the first Cubit
being one and the verifier checks
consistency and so on and then if the if
the approver cheats then he gets at some
point caught because the problem becomes
simpler and simp and simpler until we
get to the point where the prover just
needs the verifier just needs to compute
things like that which are well not easy
to compute but we can do something with
it never mind and and uh let me just end
with the fact that uh that uh I think
that understanding uh this kind of of uh
of classical encodings are very uh or or
how Quantum properties are encoded in
this um I think it's a it's a it's a
very interesting question and in
particular one way to understand this is
to ask whether it's possible to provide
such proofs for for uh using provs which
are weaker like if I allow the prover to
be only QA instead of being able to to
compute a p space complete problem um
would it be possible um so probably the
weakest problem open I can the easiest
problem I can pose here is can a Q&A
approver prove to a classical verifier a
bqp problem and that's related also that
goes back to to what I started with
that's related also to the open question
that was mentioned a lot in the previous
conference which is can we have a
verifier which is BPP and approver which
is bqb that has a quantum computer such
as the approver with a quantum computer
think d-wave can help can convince us
that what they're doing is really
solving a bpb problem by only classical
interaction so uh so let me
end there any questions right okay I
want to ask you a question I asked you
earlier but now that I heard the proof
in more detail I want to Reas it which
is um that that proof you gave for this
interactive proof to to test Q is
basically a path integral figuring out
an interactive proof for and I don't see
where you Ed that the transformations in
the path integral were coming from a you
know we're just coming from some
permission hamiltonian and that you
hadn't inserted some extra projectors on
intermediate time steps or made the
hamiltonian dependent on the time size
so wouldn't this also be an alternate
proof of that IP equals P space I think
I think it would um I don't know how how
to interpret that but I think it is true
um um I also wanted to say that it's
actually very similar to the original
I
space you also do this summation so it's
it has the same flavor the only it of
course it has the same flavor the the uh
the idea of the original the the
brilliant idea of the original Ip equals
P space proof is really that you add
redundancy and so that uh um so that
um somehow if if the prover committed to
some value then the verifier can ask
many many questions and for the answers
for these questions to be consistent
with the previous with the previous uh
answer that the approver gave well most
of them cannot be both consistent and
correct they need also to be wrong and
so uh if the F was claiming a wrong
wrong claim he sort of pushed to
claiming a wrong claim in the next step
and the only difference between uh what
I showed in and the original proof is in
the type of redundancy
um so in the original proof the
redundancy was done by
polinomial um of low degree and so this
is sort of the values of the different
Pol the polinomial at different
locations um but uh here the uh the
different the different value here is s
of the the redundancy is given by
projection on different states different
directions so a random direction of a
cubic so it's sort
of it's very similar in that this
structure is is followed but um but the
tensor product
structure is new I mean it's it's it
appears
there I don't know if it's helpful or
not but it's sort of more natural in the
quantum setting it seems that here no in
the classic you have to add this
redundancy it seems that here you don't
add this you don't need to add it it's
somehow
already inside the well you do edit
because actually if you want to compute
the trace all you need is to compute the
diagonals right you're asking about the
diagonals but here you're asking about
different directions so you're asking
about summations in different directions
so you can think of this as as uh as
redundancy
um I actually so so Matt's comment about
the path intervals I think maybe it's
possible to combine this with polinomial
over path intervals to get something
more interesting here I don't know
um I don't know but uh but but but the
point that matth made was that uh that
uh um that really this proof works not
only for for QA but it works for for pce
for the entire yeah that's why it's
strange because somehow it seems that
here you don't really need to add these
extra this
extra
redundancy so I need okay so I don't I
think this is
something are more
questions maybe then we should just
finish this session thanks
thanks